[Music]
somebody
made a new stand-up special
oh speaking of abortions
now listen
maybe this is why brendan schaub has a
new comedy special maybe this is why
they're considering overturning roe
versus wade because they're like that's
it no more abortions
that's the last one we can handle now
now listen
everybody listen bent pixels
um or brendan or whatever you're [ __ ]
you're going by now um
this is uh transformative because we are
not going to be playing your whole
special we're playing a little extra
excerpts and we're going to be providing
transformative commentary over it
and that's how this works over here okay
and also if you do try to like you know
dmca this or you try to sue us uh we're
not saying z we're not um
you know
poor
so
you we like we're not one of those like
we're one of those where your attorney
will immediately be caught
you'll actually be very impressed
with the lightning speed at which your
attorney will be immediately be
contacted by an attorney so just
throwing that out there
so uh anyway
normally when a career is going up i i'm
just just to track how careers work
now marsh you used to be in the in in
the scene so i'm gonna ask you some
questions about the craft
sure um
is the podcast about that is
the best is the is the is the the way
the order goes do you go from
a 25-minute youtube special to a
one-hour showtime special that's the
normal way of things
uh correct
uh
generally speaking no okay so here's the
thing tv specials are still kind of what
everyone wants okay so he had a showtime
special because he's friends with joe
rogan and um
now i'm sure he didn't get it on the
strength of his food truck show now his
special is on thick boy
uh the youtube channel on uh is that
like his youtube channel i assuming i
don't know i i've not followed this man
anything i know about this man is clips
on this show outside of the show i don't
really follow it
but
it's been a frozen tell me what your
showtime special came out in
if you don't mind
um and i want to say something else here
too this is going to be a fair
evaluation of this because we have not
pre-watched this
uh this was sent to me we have not
pre-watched it i mean of course i
skipped around a little bit but
this is going to be a fair assessment
um uh 2019. okay 2019. so it's been uh
it's been uh
18
80 82 weeks with eric bischoff right is
that what it's called a three week
service brush off
wrap me up on this eric oh here we go
now meltzer would go on to say that
brendan's showtime special was the
biggest abortion that ever happened in
history tell me eric have you seen
anything worse than that thing
i thought the chinese stuff was a bit
insensitive yeah
my friend sonny ono didn't care for it
now look i was i was in the crowd
however i don't remember it i honestly i
don't remember it
um
brendan
uh so he's had three years to improve
his uh
his craft as they said i bet he's that's
a lot of time i bet he got good well i'm
gonna skip ahead around i'm gonna just
skip around play little tiny segments
because you know obviously this is fair
use what we're doing here it's good to
be in dallas man you guys do it right
it's good to be in dallas i know
[Applause]
that room doesn't look as big as the
showtime one that he had
right it looks a bit small okay
there's a reason that it's improv i
think that's where stein was doing
stand-up recently oh good my special
here man you guys just give me so much
love i absolutely love texas man i uh
yeah
yeah thank you thank you
i uh i haven't touched a mask since i
touched down it is fantastic
i'm gonna skip ahead if you don't mind
we're getting into the funny stuff after
the introduction
this first day outfit looking all
[ __ ] fly dope kicks giant backpack
backwards hat looks just like me i'm
walking up for school i'm like dude it's
about to be lit as [ __ ]
i was little he's doing the funny walk
did you see the funny walk i saw the
funny one no no you didn't
i saw the funny walk
look at the funny walk i want you to
look at the funny walk i'm walking up
for school i'm like dude it's about to
be lit that's not how normal people walk
this guy will do anything he's so silly
all his little friends out front in the
first day outfits i'm like oh my god you
guys are cute as [ __ ] i need to document
this aot get tight there's a bunch of
you squeezing tight daddy's gonna take a
picture ready cheese on three ready one
two three
cheese they're all cheese
i take it on my phone i'm all hell yeah
why is he so fast what what why is he so
oh royce uh can i answer that for you
sure you know because i'm not like these
[ __ ] civilians bro okay thank you um
when you're
when you're
rushing through a set
generally it's a sign that you're not
confident in the material got it so you
resort to stool humping and funny walks
and you talk really fast see if you ever
notice
um
a lot of people that are good at comedy
like louis c.k
is a good example of somebody
guy takes his time
right he does a bit david tell same
thing takes his time on stage he doesn't
he's not like i gotta be funny i gotta
be funny i gotta be funny like they're
just they know this shit's funny you let
it build organic you let it just do it
like conversationally he knows this
material is not great he also is under
pressure because the showtime special
failed he knows how this is going to
look being so much smaller and on
youtube this needs to be a hit so he's
throwing all his energy into this it's
like a fighter isn't not confident that
they're going to be able to go the
distance
not that i'm comparing
one thing to another that's i'm not it's
not a shot at you mr schaub but like
let's say a fighter doesn't think he'll
be able to outclass an opponent over
several rounds they come in really hard
out of the gate try to end the fight
quick this is the comedy equivalent of
just trying to end the fight quick
um
hey do you want the imdb score now or
after after an idea oh boy and at the
end don't look it up don't cheat
i'm not okay good
um
something else by the way brandon i am a
fat guy so let me give you some fat guy
since now that you're turning into a fat
guy um
the big shirt works uh you want to wear
dark colors uh button up like that is
great to try to hide the belly problem
is your jeans are now too small for you
so when you hunch over your belly and by
the way this is coming from a fat guy
i'll admit it your belly is not going
over the
jeans so you have to go up you you can't
wear skinny jeans anymore buddy you have
to wear normal jeans now okay
i snap a pic i text it to my girl she
gets it she looks at she goes
crop out the uglies resend
do you think she really said that
you think his girlfriend really said
crop out the ugly look look at his face
what a funny face
he looks like someone a real housewives
that had too many surgeries
yeah or maybe just too many blows to the
face yeah seriously he looks like me
he's turning into mindy mindy kalin oh
my god he really is christ man
that's not true though because mindy
kayla wrote some office episodes so she
can be funny
what
excuse me
i said you're in a group chat to other
parents dumbass
oh bro she was dude
she was in a group chat with all the
other parents
oh
snap that didn't happen uh i'm skipping
nope we made it up fabrication skipping
ahead a bad writer wrote that one
yeah he did
well that's why i said bad writing
oh oh oh hold on hold on here we go
okay that's his spanish he wasn't
embarrassed enough when he did the
chinese one she has to do with hispanic
that's a bad hispanic accent dumbass
stuff that he does every wednesday real
mexican dishes y'all real [ __ ] from the
motherland i'm talking
what is he doing i'm i'm not okay that's
why you saw me back up was i was trying
to make sure that i was being fair and
gave him the setup
so i get you saw me you saw me go back
and give him the setup right he's just
saying silly
spanish words but he's saying it making
a gay face like what is going on
he brendan shaw is going on oh
connect
so just laugh at your own stuff i don't
get it somebody has to
i mean wouldn't you try to at least like
do it uh like look royce will vouch for
me right i don't do the best hispanic
accent but for a white boy i could do a
pretty decent little [ __ ] mexican
accent when i want to do one why would
you just go
well
that's not gay enough yeah
what are you doing you got to stick your
tongue out more we're going to hump them
we gonna suck their dicks off can we
make a brendan shop version yes
piccolo
that's how spanish people talk
and my favorite chili ah
it's funny dude because it's a funny
voice this is you know what this is you
know we talk about this but this is what
jocks think is funny
you know what i mean like this is what
like
if you were still making jokes it's like
the kids with the letterman jacket had
in high school you know yeah
yeah pretty much it that are like
rubbing their ass on your face yeah but
jocks don't know a lot of humor other
than bullying or wacky voices
every night though every night seven
years later every [ __ ] night i know i
look latin there's gonna know who i am
she's like honey what the [ __ ] is
happening right now
is he not a puerto rican shortstop for
the dodgers
shortstop
say words
sound them out before you say them what
did he say shortstop shortstop
here you want to hear us i gotta hear
shorts every night though every night
seven years later every [ __ ] night i
know i look latin there's gonna know who
i am she's like honey what the [ __ ] is
happening right now
is he not a puerto rican shortstop for
the dodgers yeah shortstop sure stop
yeah i actually went to go see a
shortstop uh he was actually he
introduced bruce springs spring at his
concert
i thought i thought in order to get
shortstop you had to go to like a
butcher because they don't usually have
it at like publix oh he's butchering
this set that's fine
that's the butchering happening there's
butchering happening for sure
yeah he should be jobbing for wardlow
what the [ __ ] happening
dude i did that 23andme i did that [ __ ]
you spin the cup email your dna in i did
that they sent me drive mayonnaise yeah
i know you did your 23 and me and they
go oh sure this is a 25 of me there's
two extra chromosomes wait he's making a
white people mayonnaise joke royce you
have to hear this you have to hear what
he just you have to play but i don't
wanna you have to hear the [ __ ] punch
line okay here we go
the dodgers what the [ __ ] happening
dude i did that 23andme i did that [ __ ]
you spin the cup email your dna in i did
that they sent me drive mayonnaise back
see royce
the joke is i heard it now
see the punch line i heard it
it's that he's so white i know
rather than giving him the the desired
results that they usually would give you
they sent a mayonnaise
huh i don't want to be around anymore
yeah no
i heard it
because mayonnaise historically
traditionally speaking is a white person
thing i'm skipping ahead
transformative
i've i
have to say that every time
and tell her my [ __ ] keto okay he
sounded like [ __ ] max caster whenever
he goes yes
corporate synergy
eight weeks goes by your boy hasn't
touched a [ __ ] tortilla nothing i
walked in the house last friday
sure enough there's a [ __ ] fiesta
bro i skipped ahead four minutes and
he's still doing the mexican food is
this entire set about mexican food royce
when you're on a roll
right i mean it doesn't matter how long
a bid is as long as it's a fire ass bit
he's not on the roll carlin used to riff
on a single premise for like 15 i'm
sorry george carlton thank you just to
riff on a single bit for like 15 minutes
some of george carlton's albums had like
six tracks on it
and this dude had the balls to [ __ ]
abandon brian callan
buddy
my favorite food
you know how like the title of this
special is called the gringo poppy
huh the gringo poppy
can't brown cocaine
yes i may ask you something who's worse
bren and schaub or people who pay to go
see brendan's shop
people that pay to go see brandon shop
i think they're worse they're worse
right i think they're worse yeah yeah
like hitler wasn't the one shoveling
[ __ ] bodies into ovens right like
not personally he had to get a lot of
bad people to listen to him right yeah
yeah of course
he was just working the room
[Music]
half the [ __ ] hitler came up with even
he was probably like i really didn't
think they'd even go for that really
frankly these people are these people
are sick well his ss just stands for
stupid [ __ ] bags
[Laughter]
jesus christ
now like he struggles with cocaine
like if there was cocaine on the table
right now he'd [ __ ] snort it from
right field you feel me
what does that mean
he's i guess maybe he's implying that
the baseball player has a big nose so he
could snort cocaine from far away i i
don't know
god bless him i love that [ __ ] dude
that's why i am with [ __ ] plasole i
see it dude i will [ __ ] take it wow
no no it's not a joke the whole thing's
about mexican food okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna skip ahead like
let me let me
at least play devil's advocate here
right sure
mexican food's pretty good right amazing
i love mexican food
that's all i have oh
that's all i had okay
i'm gonna i'm scared to defend this man
skipping ahead two minutes
one of the many things i love about the
mexican culture it
it's all mexican stuff is this a mexican
stand-up
this this is less of a comedy set and
more of a guy who really wants some
mexicans to think he's not racist
right
you ever see that
like you ever meet a white guy and then
all he'll talk about is how much he
loves cuban people yeah and you're like
okay i mean i'm cuban but i'm also other
things i don't care i have other things
i like
he's turned into carlos mencia he's a
fake mexican that talks about joe rogan
a lot
it sounds like he sounds like a guy
from like polk county
who you would meet at a bar
and his entire conversation all night
would be like oh i'm a cuban people man
i like i like y'all man you're cool
freedom man you guys don't put up with
that comedy chickens yeah man i like
food and stuff and you're like okay man
cool hey you know what i like man you
know you don't got the thing about cuban
people i really respect your people like
after a while you're like oh dude i'm
starting to feel like i'm not one
to throw racist around
but i'm starting to feel like you're
really racist hey man you really try to
overcompensate you know i'm also a
dolphins fan like there's other things
about me
you know like video games and stuff i
like tv shows i guess you should have
known i was a dolphins fan cause of the
cuban thing but you get it
you get it
i and i do love your culture man well
the many things i love about it is you
guys always have something your culture
is he doing this just in front of
mexican people because i see white
people okay but if you're gonna do that
do it at a home depot parking lot at
five in the morning he filmed this in
dallas there's white people in dallas
celebrate
every week you have something to
celebrate
as a what
whoa white person my dad's like only
your birthday [ __ ]
all right once a year be cool dad be
cool what would the asian doctor sound
like though
not mexicans every week something's
poppin
how would he make him sound or how does
he actually sounds well i know how he
sounds he sounds because he sounded like
this when i saw the remember beige that
was one of the beige frequencies best
little like gotchas was when he actually
found the doctor
uh yes my name is henry wu i'm the
doctor here at the ufc facility like
that guy is like super white guy
last week some girl turned 15.
is he gonna do five minutes of
quinceanera
i'm sorry but are you just taking george
lopez's stick what's going on here
not not even related to us
through the party at my house
apparently the mexican culture i hope
you also [ __ ] i hope he rips off his
kidney failure too yeah i'm skipping
ahead
i couldn't help it i'm skipping he's
also like george lopez where he used to
be on tv now he's on youtube
uh i'm skipping ahead but george lopez
at least has an excuse yeah true
we did not go in there dallas we did not
we're looking for dr robinson maybe dr
allen at this point you feel me
what what
a home field advantage
i moved in the house recently yeah so
did i that's relatable
i too live it well i live in an
apartment but it's kind of like a house
but smaller and stacked next to other
houses
in a new house in la whenever you move
in a new house it's always weird but
it's even weirder in the middle of
pandemic so we're moving the house my
girl goes poppy poppy i've seen the
neighbors
oh is it because his wife is mexican
maybe yeah
maybe i guess okay
cool
they're pretty old let's play it safe
they're probably covered conscious why
don't you just go over and induce
yourself right i'll pick some eggs and
cookies and you go over them like what
the [ __ ] mexican cookie what are you
talking about it's like a chocolate chip
with sauce all over it what are you
talking about
because they put salsa on everything
or maybe it's a chocolate chip cookie
with
big clicker
on it
i
want to kill yourself
yes but that's that's a baseline for me
but
that's that's how i start today wake up
um
man aren't you glad that they we have
the uh the chrome plug-in that lets you
know how many dislikes it has
oh no 26 up
61 000 down
no 26 000 up 61 thousands oh okay twenty
six thousand i thought it was twenty six
up six thousand and one down
um
you want that score now
this special
is like a chocolate chip cookie with
salsa on it
[Laughter]
that's great
this comment section is going to get
more views in the video itself so in a
way brendan schaub is bringing us more
comedy gold than he'd ever imagined
man i love when a community comes
together
oh [ __ ]
i never even smiled once watching this i
can't lie did you genuinely pay some of
these people to laugh
all right i just had to add mine andrew
somebody wrote name andrew wrote he has
been practicing he's got the joe rogan
mannerisms down
oh i just linked my comment in the chat
in case anybody's
wants to upvote that and reply to this
like
uh are you gonna sue everyone who makes
fun of this
it's a lot of lawyers
i replied
i just wrote yes
oh brendan he's so bad okay what if i
skip okay
when you so like the closing the closing
joke is the best right like that you
always you always go out strong because
you that's how everybody's gonna
remember you send them home happy
that cat's [ __ ] bro yeah i'll keep you
posted
i'll let you know man yeah thank you
dude killer deal
so i get home i'm listen i'm never going
to go i'm hyped up i'm blowing the gun i
get my [ __ ] night vision on around
like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] dope dude
wow he really is man you know i read the
comments it's he really is copying
like if you look at
the way rogan is on stage that's what
he's doing you know and i mean look
rogan's stand-up is man no i'm not
saying it's a good stand-up i'm saying
he's a stool humping idiot but he at
least has his own gimmick that's his
thing right he does that so it's like
all right at least you're doing your own
thing
i'll let you know man yeah thank you
dude killer deal
so i get home i'm listening this
hassle's [ __ ] [ __ ] walking around
his house with a viewfinder that
somebody on somebody was on rogan was i
guess lied to him to mess with him and
said it was a night vision thing he's
like i see paris click click oh now i'm
on the moon click click
sir that's a [ __ ] eight dollar toy
from the 90s
so i'm not going to
by the way viewfinders were dope yeah of
course
and night vision on ram like this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] dope dude in my head i'm like
right this is this i'm envision this
right envisioning envisioning it shows
up at 3 am every night right so i'll be
sleeping it's 3am it's late i'll be i'd
be sleeping at 3am too dawg i could
relate to this guy why would you use
night vision as home defense that
doesn't even make sense you would the
time it would take to turn it on and get
it on your head and strapped like that
you'd have to be lying in weight with
night vision on for somebody like night
vision's supposed to be
outdoors at night fighting the
government [ __ ] like there's no
sleeping right i'm here wow
what are you doing
and then i always have my uggs backwards
right my
bugs will be right there
royce you keep pausing it and we're not
getting the comedy
look unless i switch to patrice o'neill
video we're not gonna be getting any
comedy
so let's start with that
secondly he did that thing where if
you're funny enough you could pull it
off but he did that thing where he says
uggs and then he looked at the crowd and
he was like yeah
i said uggs yeah that's right i wear
uggs
jesus christ he looked at the camera
like sammy gavartas before he jumps off
a ladder
wow i'm a [ __ ] pop out of bed right
i'm a [ __ ] yeah
i wish brennan schaub just did his set
like holding up [ __ ] cue cards god
that would be [ __ ] great i got my
uggs bedside right my uggs will be right
there
huh
huh
guys don't wear uggs merch that's so
funny this guy's pretty wacky he's
irreverent
he's you said irrelevant wrong
oh that's looking great brandon brandon
brendan
be cool tom brady we're so [ __ ]
i have an idea why don't you be cool
first
guy who parks at the [ __ ] at the
comedy club in front of with his porsche
even though he's only been doing it for
three years or other [ __ ] people
schlubs have to park in the back i slide
myself cubics in the chat said [ __ ]
dolph ziggler is better at stand-up
comedy cubix draws is better at stand-up
comedy
right i'll have my ar-15 like this and
by zero dark top london it's better at
stand-up comedy
duty night vision like this my big
dick's right there still
it's big dicks right there dude yeah
let's get a big dick bro cool
i don't know why i threw that in but be
cool so i'm [ __ ] here be cool bro he
doesn't know he threw that in
she's so offended so i'm here right
so i'm here she's so offended but the
only thing that offends me is you think
this is comedy and people you charge
people for this that's what offends me
brendan yeah the only thing you're
offending is any uh
any [ __ ] comedy audience member of
good taste and i catch my ground like
enough's enough dude i'm gonna slide
that sliding door open like yeah
and every video just making noises
yeah you know i've ever seen like online
those mountain lions have like those
soft wet black noses i'm gonna pump them
right in that goddamn nose [ __ ]
and then
you have an automatic
you have a machine machine you want a
machine gun so you want a a gun that was
manufactured before 1963
and also
you're gonna
open up automatic gunfire in a
residential neighborhood
just to get a mountain lion
we haven't seen this do you do we want
to guess the punchline what was it
wasn't really a mountain lion what do
you i mean it can't be right because
what would the joke be it turned out to
be what
a black guy home invading um
a taco truck
given the theme got it got it
i'm looking my ring camera and go world
star
wait so the cats are the mountain lions
out in the front yard and you're going
to open fire with a machine gun
across the across the street
it's all very confusing
your boy's gonna go viral it's gonna be
lit as [ __ ] i can't wait man
okay opie why don't you relax
is that next night right i'm pacing back
and forth my girl's like go to bed i'm
all shut up [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] here
he's doing the same thing over and over
and over again
this isn't jokes this isn't even prop
comedy but it's not even really physical
comedy what do you call this
[ __ ]
i call it [ __ ]
what well i know like the bigger picture
of it it's [ __ ] you asked a question i
give you a [ __ ] answer don't ask me a
question i met what style of comedy is
this
um [ __ ] shitty
it's the rogan style he got worse smears
he got worse
because he's doing the same bad material
but now with more energy how did you get
worse brendan
have you learned nothing
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
again i got my ugg boots on i get my
you know what's funny when you're when
you when you know your joke didn't work
the first time so you keep repeating the
ugg boots part
yeah it'll it'll pop off eventually also
the joke doesn't even make sense like
it's a bad joke but i guess if you're
trying to be the wacky one then i put my
crocs on because that's something that
somebody might slip on in their house
instead of sandals or whatever
but ugg boots aren't like you can't just
slip your feet into boots you know you
have to sit down and actively put them
on
they are 15.
i get my zero dark 30 night vision on
right
still got the big dick sorry i'm [ __ ]
here
i had i gotta stick with it right so i'm
here you know
you don't have to stick with it
and and then by that we mean by it we
mean comedy yeah
[Laughter]
i'm basically i'm looking at the clock
it's all 250 i'm all pretty god this cat
shows up bro it's 2 59 like last day on
earth for you kitty
3 am hits i hear ram all show time
not anymore you aren't seeing showtime
anymore sir you're saying
i didn't even think of that oh no
you should have screamed youtube
so i hear rare and i go siso
and i run outside
i heard wow when i said rev share
man swear i am i got my night vision on
my big dick staying around three am i
hear around i'm thinking roku
not a great battle cry
brain job sucks
oh [ __ ]
oh
he's not good
he's not good
oh what makes you say that
my eyes my ears all my senses their
reviews
which he's frozen's going to tell us in
a second
here's the thing dallas i uh
i've never seen a mountain lion in
person before
oh it's the misdirect what's it gonna be
it's going to be a regular cat i'm just
going to be a regular cat
it's going to be a hallucination from
the traumatic brain injury he suffered
in the u.s he's going to get so hard in
the head it's going to end tragically
with him shooting one of his kids with
an ar-15 delirious
because the seat the combination of the
cte and the night vision and all the
weed
makes him go delirious now people like
this is going to start it's going to end
with him shooting himself in the chest
so they could preserve his brain for
scientific study like junior seoul
[ __ ] christ you suck bro
in my head i was thinking like a small
type of bobcat type of thing right like
the gun's a little extreme i don't need
the navy seal night vision so you don't
like okay so for this joke to work we
have to assume that you had a mountain
lion problem and you never googled what
a mountain lion looked like and you
thought it was the size of a bobcat
i hate him oh yeah he's not great okay
why was it the punch line i love i love
that he just also tells these
elaborate stories that aren't true well
because you're right like like look
again i think he's trying to do like you
said like the the the george carlton as
he called them you know or like like you
said like the louis ck where you you'll
sit there and he'll get you invested
dave chappelle's great at stories too
right like oh dave chappelle probably
one of the best yeah like unraveling a
story slowly
like the baby smoking weed yeah yeah
he'll get you hooked into a story but
like you're not a story storyteller
you're an idiot
you're an idiot with undeserved
success
by the way hong kong said to be fair a
lot of comics do that but they're better
at it no but the difference is a lot of
comics when they're telling a story
even if it's not
their story right it might be a story
they heard
it's it's usually the baseline of the
story the foundation of the story will
be true
and then they embellish it for comedic
effect what i'm saying is none of this
happened he just heard a cat outside one
night he probably heard a stray
and he went
oh man it was a mountain lion or
something and then he was like oh [ __ ]
honey i gotta get get my imac i gotta go
i gotta write i think i just came up
with a brilliant bit yeah
you can probably grab it by the scruff
of the neck and be like enough's enough
kitty
first off you couldn't grab a bobcat by
the scruff of the neck a bobcat would
still [ __ ] your world up it would shred
dude i can't even pick my cat up by the
scruff of its neck unless i want to have
some nice [ __ ] deep gashes in my arms
and shits
well no dumbass it's a line of the
mountains dude it's [ __ ]
this thing was mufasa [ __ ]
it's like this mountain lion ate joe
rogan's trash this is and there it is
and there it is
your closer is a name drop of joe rogan
that's right
is he has he not learned
from any
of the [ __ ]
criticisms that have been levied at him
i i guess not
um
[Applause]
oh i panicked dude i bet i went oh [ __ ]
and i slammed the door
dude
a mountain lion that was digging through
joe rogan's trash so a mountain lion
that was stoned and probably also ate
some of tim dillon's calm okay come on
what
i [ __ ] threw my night vision i'm not
even left-handed i was like oh my god
sorry about my ugg boots still got the
big dick not a big deal
sorry
i got that ring out whoa app the next
morning yo we got a mountain lion
problem y'all
i love you guys what
what no no i didn't skip i did not skip
what was that a hard cut can i be honest
with you
i just i feel like i just you know when
you like okay you know when you're
driving like late at night
you know when you like doze off for like
two seconds
that's what that felt like it felt like
you were driving and you dozed off for a
second and you come back and you're like
listening to something and then you're
like
well i missed part of this
wow
i mean again we didn't play the whole
thing we skipped through it but that for
what we saw that is really [ __ ] bad
dude
we see that cut again
[Music]
sorry i uh
i got that ring app the next morning
like yo we got a mountain lion problem
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
so that was worse than the first one
right
that was
like exponentially worse than the first
one wow on imdb it is 1.1
you're gonna give away some [ __ ] cbd
products to
pump them numbers up again
and then uh his previous one was 1.6 out
of 10.
so he got that was after the bribes so
he yes so he got worse
yes
wow
that was brendan stop please that was
a video on the internet please stop sure
for all of us
hey can you scroll all the way back to
the beginning of that video you don't
have to watch it just even pause the
brendan video i want yeah i wanted to
show
i wanted to show you the the the hint
that this was gonna be a great night if
you go all the way to the beginning
when everyone's lined up outside the gym
celinski was there
zielinski was there well you know
wow
he's trying to get a lot of uh you know
good uh good press for the uh for
ukraine and he figured nothing will make
ukrainians look more like victims than
if he sat through a brendan shop comedy
special wow the line goes all the way to
the jimmy john's that's that was why i
wanted to scroll back i was pointing it
out yeah
right outside the jimmy john's
so the food was as good as the comedy
that's not true i like jimmy john's um
zen rhino jeffrey epstein was spotted at
a beefy king on north bumby avenue in
orlando arguing with the johnny trep
trial while eating a hot reuben sandwich
and beefy spuds okay come on yeah that's
pretty good north bumpy avenue he
flipped the [ __ ] he flipped the
script on us yeah i thought it was gonna
be dominic mysterio and somebody said
check this out
i i if you sent me links in the middle
of the show
i will kill you yeah but i think it's
this hold on it looks like he's being
interviewed
shot on the side
here we go
brendan i think right now is the time
that i tell you how proud i am of you
but the real word is impressed
not surprised you keep making [ __ ]
happen i'm just proud of you
what's up mr thick boy himself i want to
congratulate you on your second special
very proud of you buddy two specials
i've got zero you already have two is he
crying
i wanted to say this man congratulations
on the special baby
i'm proud of you it's your second
special and it's gonna do great things
for you i know a lot of people will see
it you've been working really hard you
should be really proud of yourself and
notice something with him that's not me
frozen notice something
he's fake crying it's well not only the
fake crying but but but oh god oh god oh
god this is great notice something here
you could this is why you could tell
comics do not respect him
no other comic what other comics have to
get around and be like you're doing so
good you're special so great no other
comic would be coddled you want to know
how a real comic would make if merch had
a new special here's what i'd say i'd be
like it's just probably gonna suck isn't
it you [ __ ] losers hey where can they
catch your mid act because that's how
real friends and real comics are secure
about whether they're good or not talk
to each other they don't go and you
don't [ __ ] sit there and cry like a
little girl brendan
dude there was a [ __ ] great line from
uh mike racine i think it was mike
racine special
he filmed his at the comedy cellar
and his opened up with a bunch of
comedians [ __ ] on him
at the beginning of course and one of
the clips was rich foss going oh yeah
congratulations you're working at the
comedy cellar now so do a bunch of cooks
but that's how they are
i know a lot of people will see it
you've been working really hard you
should be really proud of yourself and i
just wanted to congratulate you brother
on your second special the gringo poppy
royce
congratulations on your second special
that was a downgrade from showtime
it's not me frozen for downgrade to
showtime to here also like
congratulating him on a self-produced
special
but you notice nobody's saying even
let's say okay fine let's say that
they're not
la comics aren't like new york comics
they're not going to [ __ ] on each other
as much as the new york comics do they
would at least be saying stuff like bro
congrats on your new special dude it's
brilliant it was so [ __ ] funny man i
left my [ __ ] ass off bro i'm proud of
you none of them are saying that well
michael wright basically saying they're
just saying
congratulations for filming a set that's
all they're congratulating you for like
if i just put like dough and sauce and
cheese and then took a [ __ ] on a platter
and then baked it
and you went congratulations i guess you
i guess yeah that's a pizza i've had
hawaiian pizza before i know what you
mean
michael rappaport is a new york comic
though you could tell because it's not a
comic because of the two stars of david
congratulations on your second
special here why are you crying 19 and
20 more always bet on shop hasn't failed
me yet what
did you see the reaction have you seen
the ratings what's up b congratulations
on getting your second special i just
want to congratulate you on your special
doing it so this means that like
somebody went around shoving cameras and
all these guys faces and said please say
something nice about brendan john is
special get all together yourself this
is worse than the bribing your own
network it's an amazing your own network
he's got a network yeah a thick boy what
channel is it on it's on youtube it's on
a youtube channel oh granddad just want
to say congratulations on your second
special gringo papi hey what up chef i
just want to uh say congrats on your
special man i'm glad you're finally
they're so nice to him because he's the
[ __ ] child
this does not happen with anybody else
in your mexican brothers the grammy in
the chat said it looks like a bunch of
cameos can you yes can you imagine
like let's use can you imagine bill burr
crying to people saying his special was
good like i'm just thinking of other
comics right like can you imagine him
crying no one would be crying funny i
can't wait to see it man congrats i saw
it sir and you can't wait to see it
congrats on number two it's a testament
to you as a person hey that's what to
say some workaholics and congratulations
it's a testament to you as a person
what does that even mean in the context
of being a comedian
i haven't heard one person yet say
wow man that was some funny [ __ ] dude
you're a funny [ __ ] you're a
killer dude you're a murderer you've
earned it man
you deserve it
daddy oh daddy congratulations she went
for being on dynamite to ew dark
we love you and we are so proud of you
congratulations congratulations you're
the ruby soho of comedy
oh no
oh that means the world to me thank you
i'm done i i i mean that's it
i don't even want to do this show
anymore i don't want to do life anymore
i don't
what is wrong you're an adult man
i'm telling you nothing better shows you
what kind of relationship they have with
him versus any other comic
they have to baby him and tell him he's
doing good or they won't get on rogan or
they won't get on rogan